salvi youtubers benvenuti ad una nuova
recensione prima di iniziarla vorrei
dirvi una cosa
siccome ci sono state nell'ultimo
periodo molte discussioni sul profilo
del mio canale di youtube ho deciso di
creare un forum chiamato io sono qui
punto forumfree punto it e niente mi
piacerebbe se partecipaste se volete
ovviamente il link lo trovate nelle
informazioni di questo video e nelle
informazioni del mio camere di youtube
come al solito grazie
allora il film che vogliono recensire
oggi e avatar il film tanto discusso da
tutto il mondo ce credo sia il film più
discusso di degli ultimi dieci anni
perché il film come sappiamo tutti ha
guadagnato di più nella storia del
cinema e il film che ha guadagnato di
più nella storia del cinema quindi è un
evento importante per gli amanti del
cina e siccome il mio canale
principalmente di cinema ho detto non
posso tirarmi indietro per dare anche la
mia opinione visto che moltissimi
volevano averla quindi
farò questo video molto molto
velocemente molto diretto come ormai
sapete tutti mi piace fare con voi voi
siete il mio feedback quindi io vi parlo
come se voi fosse veramente lì davanti
io lo sto parlando come la telecamera il
suo parlano veramente con voi e altre
stronzate del genere comunque come di
cercherò di farlo senza tagliare come
faccio di solito ve ne parlo come se
fossi vostro amico allora
ci sono tante cose di cui dovrei parlare
di avatar
però partiamo dall'inizio allora
partiamo dalla prima cosa che tutti
hanno visto di avatar
il trailers
il trailer di avatar e e spettacolare
dal punto di vista del montaggio della
musica ma è atroce c a me non è piaciuto
proprio il trailer di avatar perché ti
riassume tutta la storia tra nel finale
ti riassume tutto quanto tutto tutto c'è
e dura tre minuti e mezzo una roba
infinita ce lo guardi e bellissimo per
carità però no tu poi vai al cinema e
sei già tutto tutto io sapevo che c'è
nel trailer faccio vedere che lui era
dalla parte di marin andavano lì per le
quella pietra lì che è costata
tantissimo la usano gli avatar per
entrare a contatto con questi alieni lui
si allea con gli alieni per fare la
battaglia finale poi se ci pensionati ma
il finale potevi intuirlo ma questo ne
parliamo dopo no adesso rimasto così ha
detto ma perché devi far vedere tutto il
vii il time non deve riassumere i film
deve darti le linee generali di quella
che potrebbe essere la trama del film e
basta poi metterci immagini del film
ovviamente musica bella ma non troppo
riassumere perché sennò ti rovina tutto
e vabbè io sono un po contrario a queste
cose
e va bene
poi io ombre premetto che sono andato a
vedere il film
completamente privato dalla mia mente di
tutto quello che hanno detto su avatar
fino a quel momento perché tutti mi
dicevano no devi andarlo a vedere perché
troppo bello no non l'ho guardare perché
fa schifo ma c e finché non lo guardo io
non posso esprimere opinioni mi sono
andato a vederlo e
sgombrando la mia mente come dicevano i
matrix c'è dimenticandomi tutto facendo
finta che
fosse stato fosse un film normalissimo
come tutti gli altri
ho detto vado a vederlo così senza
aspettarmi in è un capolavoro né una
schifezza quindi la mia opinione si basa
anche su questo io l'ho considerato un
film normale
una cosa che non mi è piaciuta di avatar
subito è l'inizio l'inizio non mi è
proprio piaciuto c'è perché è troppo
troppo troppo veloce c'è nei primi venti
minuti ti danno tante di quelle
informazioni ma allo stesso tempo non te
ne dà nessuna c'è
chi dice che lui ha avuto il fratello
che è andato in guerra lui ha perso le
gambe lui si risveglia dopo non mi
ricordo quanto tempo
ibernati o comunque addormentati si
risvegliano che si sono praticamente già
arrivati su pandora il pianeta dei na'vi
non ti non ti spiega bene così è
successo sulla terra non ti spiega
perché stanno cercando questa cosa che
costa tanto non ti spiega niente poi per
il film qualcosa intuisce ma all'inizio
è tutto tutto veloce infatti ci sono
rimasto parecchio mar detto no non puoi
far partire un film così è già
abbastanza abbastanza sbagliato la
seconda cosa che mi è saltato subito
dall'occhio sono gli attori che per
carità non sono qui quegli attori
allucinanti
però il protagonista che io non ho mai
visto ma mi sono ricordato di averlo
visto in terminator salvation se
ricavato parecchio bene nel suo ruolo
veramente mi sono sono stupito cenno non
è obbligatorio veramente prendere atto
ronnie c'è sarebbe stato consigliato
però c'è se la sono cavata benissimo
quindi li e per fare stato perfetto
poi cos'altro allora
la prima cosa che mi ha mi ha subito
fatto capire l'impatto emotivo che mi
avrebbe dato tutto il film proprio mi ha
fatto sobbalzare e
la prima scena cella la prima scena dove
appare purtroppo non mi ricordo i nomi
scusate la prima scena appare la ragazza
navi quella di cui poi il protagonista
si innamorerà
quando lo salva nel pezzo di notte
quando quando lo salva da quella
sottospecie di cani che lo aggrediscono
lei ne uccide una facendo quel rituale
che di solito fanno in amico anno
uccidono gli animali e lui continuava a
dirle grazie grazie mille grazie per
avermi salvato è lì da un certo punto si
gira arrabbiati dice nomi del iii b e
non mi devi ringraziare perché quello
che è successo è sbagliato e lui non
doveva morire sei morto e per colpa tua
e io gli ho detto madonna santa sia per
l'impatto emotivo forte e se per
l'animazione facciale dei na'vi c'è
della della ragazza comunque dei na'vi
in generale perché molti a cui ho
chiesto com'era avatar
mi hanno detto vabbè bebè gli effetti
speciali sono belli ma vabbè però la
storia fa schifo no no non fate come
tutti che accantonano gli effetti
speciali perché va bene noi ormai siamo
abituati a vedere qualsiasi tipo di
effetti speciali da quelli squali di
tipo mega shark vs giant octopus a
quelli spettacolari tipo questo ma no io
non ho mai visto niente di simile e io
come sapete ho visto abbastanza film
l'animazione facciale di navi in
particolare qualcosa di sorprendente
quindi non sono abbate così gli effetti
speciali perché sono ci sono importanti
ma mai come in questo caso perché se
avessero animato i na'vi come shrek c'è
nulla da togliere shaq che animato bene
ma se l'avessero animato con quelle
espressioni facciali di un po così
non avrebbe se preso la stessa cosa qua
solo umane proprio sono umani ditemi se
non avete il sen se non riesce a una
lacrimuccia quando l'albero sacro
gigante viene abbattuto e ci sono tutti
i na'vi che urlano per la disperazione
ditemi se non vi stavate mettendo a
piangere visti
e
allora parliamo della trama che la cosa
più discussa di tutto il film
così le più grandi stronzate lui le ho
sentite io c'è è uguale a pocahontas e
questa è la cosa che hanno detto di più
è uguale a balla coi lupi è uguale all
ultimo samurai ma scusate pensateci un
attimo e è vero che ha delle somiglianze
e impossibile negarlo è vero però scusa
era scusate perché allora quando è
uscito balla coi lupi non è stato detto
che roma la pocahontas allora perché
quando è uscito l'ultimo samurai non è
stato detto che era uguale a balla coi
lupi che era uguale a pocahontas perché
non l'hanno fatto perché l'hanno fatto
adesso c'è lo sapete perché non ha fatto
adesso perché si parla molto di avatar
allora ci deve essere sempre qualcuno
che ci devono andare contro per forza ci
puoi essere obiettivo quanto vuoi ma non
puoi dirmi che avatar è un brutto film
no è impossibile poi dirmi che la trama
forse banale puoi dirmi che gli effetti
speciali ci sono solo effetti speciali e
va bene ma non puoi dire che è un film e
brut è impossibile
una cosa particolare con cui ho parlato
di cui ho parlato molto con il span teo
alcuni di voi lo conoscono è un mio
amico e il fatto della del rapporto che
hanno i na'vi con il loro pianeta e con
la natura sul loro pianeta qualcosa di
fenomenale è uno dei punti principali di
tutto il film questo
che perché quando mi me la detto mia era
proprio entusiasta di questo mi diceva
hanno un rapporto bellissimo
c'è il loro pianeta e lo trattano come
se fosse veramente vivo e poi c'è questa
divinità
tutti gli alberi gli animali li trattano
veramente ma veramente bene e mi hanno
stupito detto beh sì è una cosa bella
effettivamente ma non pensavo così bella
perché lui non mi aveva detto che
avevano un rapporto fisico proprio
fisico con la natura infatti che l'ha
visto
ha visto che i na'vi anno in una treccia
che finisce con dei tentacoli ni con cui
loro si collegano alla natura per
pregare per parlare e per ascoltare e
stupende una cosa è poetico veramente
poetico e
tocco di classe veramente da non
sottovalutare
poi va bene questa trama abbastanza
banale tra virgolette non è banale la
trama non mi piace dire banale
preferisco dire semplice è semplice la
trama è una cosa c'è adesso faccio un po
di filosofia da filosofia da quattro
soldi quindi per domandatevi se dico
stronzate comunque secondo me ogni film
sulla faccia della terra
va considerato come una piccola poesia
nel senso quando poi analizzato nella
poesia la state tanto a guardare
l'argomento della poesia ma tutto quello
che guardate voi è il resto c'è
la forma della poesia cioè le parole
usate per la poesia la musicalità della
poesia il ritmo della poesia e
soprattutto il messaggio della poesia
poi c'è quante poesie ci sono sul su
campi di concentramento c'è solo
all'infinito e c'è gente che ha scritto
interi libri di poesie sui campi di
concentramento eppure non tutte hanno lo
stesso impatto emotivo non tutte sono
belle quindi la stessa cosa di film c'è
molti anno fa ha avuto questa trama ma
secondo me anche molto prima di avatar 6
e se ci pensiamo un attimo ci sono film
anche western primari avatar che avevano
una storia simile comunque
quindi avatar non è l'unico però è uno
dei pochi che a questo impatto emotivo
veramente molto molto forte cosa che a
me almeno pocahontas non ha dato per
quanto mi ricordi l'ho visto parecchio
tempo fa non perché sia un film per
bambino sia un film
di animazione non vuol dire nulla
e che non mi ha suscitato le non mi ha
dato i colpi allo stomaco che mi ha dato
avatar è in quei casi quindi poi dicono
tanto ma la trama di avatar
come mi ha detto alla mia ragazza è
diversa da quella di pocahontas c'è e
sviluppate in modo diverso mentre in
avatar jake sully
apprende la cultura di navi proprio ieri
i rituali le frasi linguaggio eccetera
in pocahontas il cacciatore che va in
questo villaggio di indiani non impara
niente c'è poca ultras non insegna nulla
quindi ma e poi soprattutto il finale
c'è in pocahontas lui se ne va invece in
avatar lui rimane però infatti io ho
subito detto scommetto 10.000 miliardi
di euro d'oro che rimane lì e in effetti
c'è ancor prima di vederlo proprio prima
prima di vederlo ho detto rimane lì ed
effettivamente rimane lì alla fine però
io pensavo fosse molto banale ho detto e
scontatissimo che lui rimanga lì però di
solito nei film scontati il protagonista
rimane sempre solo perché si innamora
del
del protagonista della protagonista
femminile non è solo questo
assolutamente no molti mi hanno detto e
si innamora e rimane lì è ovvio no non è
così ovvio perché lui non è solo per
quello che rimane lì rimane lì anche per
tutto quello che c'è per difendere tutto
quello che pandora per difendere diciamo
l'universo in senso stretto di pandora
la natura e tutti i loro rituali lui
ormai si è affezionato tanto a quella
terra infatti dice è lui che urla questa
è la nostra terra e la nostra terra
addirittura alla terra a tutti gli
animali a tutte le piante alle divinità
che si sono lì quindi non è sola la navi
a tenerlo lì è proprio tutto
si sono lamentati del fatto che lui vada
contro gli umani mai ci si sarebbe
andato chiunque quando che ci sarei
andato io avrei spaccato una tazzina in
testa quel sergente vita dai lo
avrebbero fatto tutti c'è la cattiveria
veramente ci sono delle scene veramente
magistrati per esempio dove fanno vedere
quando abbattono l'albero e cade tutti
che piangono tutti che strilla e tu
spettatore comune se li a tenerti lo
stomaco a piangere poi subito troppo
taglia dal comandante che beve rattazzi
ne dice
ottimo lavoro e dei mesi utili non
voglia di prendere appunti il tuo vicino
di miseno
massacri ed è c'è una cosa che non tutti
i film sanno fare secondo me
poiché csaba speso 250 milioni di
dollari che una cifra spropositata cs
lugan da tutta luce l se lo dai
all'uganda sopravvive per tutta la vita
poi per il finale va beh l'ho detto non
è proprio così scontato però io
preferisco adoro veramente ma questa è
una cosa mia i finali tragici dove c'è
un perché 13 il tragici finali che non
ti aspetteresti mai infatti io ho detto
no non lo fa è impossibile infatti non
l'ha fatto però è stato meno così ce2 mi
sembra sono morti la dottoressa e la
ragazza che poi con l'elicottero si
converte
ed è stato un buon colpo quello perché
non pensavo penso che si salvassero
tutti e invece sono morti quindi mi fa
piacere ovviamente tra virgolette non
che mi siano morti ma che ci sia stato
quel colpo di scena se ci fosse stato un
vero colpo di scena finale dove morivano
tutti o non lo so qualcos'altro sarebbe
stato ancora meglio comunque ma questi
sono pareri miei
che altro dire la parte principale di
firme quel blocco in cui lui
sta a contatto con i na'vi insegna tutto
poi si converte eccetera quindi non c'è
altro da dire su quel pezzo libro
l'unica cosa che vorrei puntare prima di
finire e la psicologia del protagonista
jake sully che di solito nei film
kolossal
poche volte mettono una psicologia
complessa di solito nei film che hanno
una trama del genere
il protagonista non ha mai ripensamenti
c'è se lui si converte si converte
linearmente invece jack sully alti bassi
infatti nel suo video log quando si
riprende da solo e parla con la
telecamera ogni tanto a dei ripensamenti
cioè ci sono alcune scene dove lo dice
proprio ma che cazzo stai facendo jack
sully cioè come per dire ma ti ricordi
da che parte giochi e questi
ripensamenti anche se sono pochi e
proprio briciole intorno al film
a me sono mi son piaciuti cemi e mi ha
dato l'impressione che fosse vero
diciamo quindi per me è un capolavoro si
merita tutti i miliardi di dollari che
sta guadagnando né si aspetta che arrivi
dvd mi dispiace che non sono riuscito a
mettere immagini ma per problemi di
diritti d'autore perché ancora al cinema
e soprattutto perché non c'è il dvd in
commercio non ho potuto farlo mettere lì
mi hanno detto metti le immagini del
thrive ma ho preferito di no perché le
immagini il trend son quelle e per
quello che dovevo dire alcune cose
mancavano quindi vi prego di perdonarmi
se non vi è piaciuta tanto la recensione
questo era un mio commento riguardo al
film e mi piacerebbe sapere cosa ne
pensate voi perché molti hanno discusso
quindi se volete discutetene sul forum
oppure potete fare benissimo un video di
risposta a questo o lasciare un commento
quindi ci vediamo alla prossima
recensione ci sarà una sorpresa è nata
una nuova categoria di film che poi
delle reti
[Musica]